Sarah. What are you seeing so far?
That's right, Kate.
You know, essentially
what we have gotten
here is only a couple of pages
from the report.
You know,
as they were just saying,
the judge is holding a lot of this back,
including the recommendations
on whether anyone
should be charged with certain c
But the one section they did
release is frankly just a paragr
on the grand jury's belief that
lied before them.
In this paragraph,
they recommend
that the Fulton County District
Fani Willis,
consider indicting
some of these witnesses for perj
So this section of the report
says the grand jury recommends
that the district attorney
seek appropriate indictments
for such crimes
where the evidence is compelling
So this kind of gives you a sens
of the tone of the grand jury,
the belief that there were witne
that came before them,
that lied under oath
and their suggestion
to the district attorney,
because ultimately up to her
whether she's going
to personally indictments,
that there may be indictments
worth pursuing
when it comes to this perjury qu
Now, again,
we're not seeing
what their broader recommendatio
We're not seeing the names of wi
that they believed may have lied
But that's important.
You know,
they also wrote
in this report
that they believe
unanimously that there
was no widespread fraud
in the 2020 election in Georgia
that could have upended the resu
Obviously,
a lot of people around the forme
president, the former president,
have contended that there was fr
despite the lack of evidence the
And they point out
that they heard
from some witnesses
who were still adamant
that there was this kind of frau
in the 20, 20 election Kate.
Interesting.
Sara, stick with me, if you will
because Patricia this question
and this paragraph
I've got a hard
copy of Sarah's
perfectly describing
the very limited amount
that's coming forward.
And it says that the grand major
of the grand
jury believes
that perjury
may have been committed by one
or more witnesses testifying bef
And I know that you were thinkin
kind of going into this,
this could be one of the most
interesting parts
of what could coming out.
What do you think it's going to?
What do you think it means?
There have no names.
We're not getting any names here
Obviously,
Well,
first of all, it lets us know
that this process is going forwa
It looks like
if there's been this recommendat
that's certainly something
that Fanny Willis
will take very seriously.
And that's an entire bucket
of potential charges
above and beyond other recommend
that may have been made
by this special grand jury.
But something that Michael Moore
so true it's so important.
There is no playbook
for what we are seeing here.
There has never been a president
indicted on criminal charges bef
We certainly have never had
this kind of finding
that there was no widespread
fraud,
followed by these layers
and layers and layers of actions
by a former president and his as
And when you look
at the list of witnesses who wen
this grand jury,
the governor,
the secretary of state,
multiple state lawmakers,
Rudy Giuliani, Mark Meadows,
Cassidy Hutchison, his own
assistant up there in the White
we start to get a glimpse
of just how broad and serious
the situation is.
Some of those witnesses
were there to say,
I don't think anything happened
and I don't believe there was fr
And here's what else I know.
Others were named as targets in
in this investigation. As well.
And when funny was asked
that this report be kept
mostly under wraps,
which is is
that exactly
what we're seeing here today?
She said she wanted to protect t
process rights
of potential future defendants.
And I think we are starting to s
that we are going to expect
future defendants in this situat
More than likely.
Michael, what do you think about
I think she's exactly right.
I don't think there's any questi
that we're going to see indictme
come out of this investigation.
I think that the D.A.
wouldn't have had the time
and treasure invested into the c
to be at this place.
Now, whether or not
she decides to proceed
on the perjury charges.
I mean, I think that's an intere
way to go. I think that might be
But it strikes me
that she's probably going
to really take these recommendat
take the testimony that she's go
And she probably bolstered up
the evidence
that she needed
to surrounded
that call
that Trump
made to the secretary of state
or at the time looking for those
And I think at that point
now she's going to move forward.
So
I don't know how broad the net w
But, you know, we do have key pl
she has subpoenaed.
And I think you're going to have
who both may have told half trut
and complete falsehoods
when they testified
and gave testimony before the
General Assembly
committees that were looking int
And you may also have people
who made false statements
or the grand jury
at least believe made
false statements to them.
And so that
that compounds the investigation
So again, whether she looks
at a few potential targets
or the key players
or she just try to indict the
the quarterback,
or does she go down
and try to indict the whole team
I don't know how deep she'll go.
She's got to be thinking, though
you know,
I need to both be able
to prove a case
beyond a reasonable doubt,
which would be the criminal stan
And if I get a conviction,
if a court lets me move forward
based on all the motions
that we're going to see
if I get a conviction,
can I support that conviction
on appeal in this state?
And she's weigh
in those things out at the same
So hopefully,
you know her comments about
the indictments
being imminent
or decisions being imminent.
We'll see those in
relatively short order.
Yeah,
they feel more imminent today
as portions of this or now
are now being released. That's f
Sara, you have some more reporti
What are you hearing?
Well, yeah,
you know, I think,
you know, as
everyone is just talking
about a lot of the tone
that we've heard
from the district attorney,
from the judge
in this case,
the sort of tone we're getting f
very limited amount of informati
from the special
grand juries report suggests
that indictments are likely.
And I think,
you know, a lot of what
all of this just points to how m
deference there is being given
to the district attorney in this
If you look at the conclusion ag
which was one of the portions
of this released,
the special grand jury,
make sure that they want to poin
that if they fail
to include
any violations,
they say we acknowledge the disc
of the district attorney
to seek indictments
where she finds sufficient cause
So essentially
what they're saying here is,
you know, in the portions
that we are not seeing,
but that they have written,
we've made a number
of recommendations of who,
if anyone should face criminal c
But they're saying
in this conclusion, look,
if there's anything we missed,
we are not legal experts.
If there was something
we missed in the statute,
if there was some crime
that was committed,
that somehow evaded us
during this investigation.
But where the district attorney
there is enough evidence
to pursue another indictment.
We defer to her.
She should go forward and do thi
So I think, you know,
that's just sort of
setting up the landscape
for as we move forward,
what will the district attorney
And how closely will it align to
what the special grand
jury has recommended?
And so this may speak
to kind of one thing
that I know everyone was looking
when this came out, which was
what is the kind of overall
tone of the parts of the report
that were released,
since we know so much is going t
was going to be
and clearly is being held back.
Is that kind of the takeaway tha
so far
as just like this amount of defe
I also do
you pointed to
and I just want to make sure,
you know,
for the statement of history,
Sara, what you said is that in t
I think this is from the opening
of the grand jury report
where they lay out very clearly
that the grand jury heard
extensive testimony on the subje
of alleged election
fraud from poll workers.
Investigators technical experts
and state of Georgia employees
and officials,
as well as some persons still cl
that such fraud took place.
And we find by a unanimous vote
that no such that no widespread
took place in Georgia
in the Georgia 20, 20
presidential election
that could result
in overturning the election.
I mean, it's an important statem
just for historical purposes. Sa
It is an important statement.
And I think, you know,
what you're seeing here is
we may not be getting
the juiciest parts right.
What everyone really wants to se
is what
this special grand jury recommen
as far as who,
if anyone, should face crimes
and on what basis.
But what we are getting here
is sort of an outline
of how they approached this,
how seriously they undertook thi
They lay out, you know,
we heard from 75 witnesses.
We heard from people
who are technical experts in thi
who still want
to make the inaccurate claim
that there was this widespread f
And we have reached what, you kn
the special grand jury believes
is this undeniable conclusion
that there was no widespread fra
in the 2020 election,
regardless of what the former pr
may be saying
about this, regardless
of what a number of his allies
may be saying about this.
And I think in that introduction
they're really laying out for th
you know, we did our homework he
This was not a surface
level investigation.
This was a deep dove
with a number of witnesses
all across the spectrum
of election administration
and as well as these public offi
to reach this conclusion.
And then again, in the conclusio
you get that deference to the D.
this notion
that ultimately it's going to be
to Fanny Willis to decide
who she really believes
she can make the case against.
Is it everyone they may have rec
in this special grand jury repor
Is it
fewer than that
or could it
potentially go even further than
this grand jury recommended?
Michael, what do you think about
Well, I
think that this
basically and if you
if you think about it,
sort of a one sentence report.
This is basically the grand jury
go get them, Madam District Atto
We've looked at the evidence.
We've heard from the witnesses.
And we think that there's
there's room for a case.
So go go get them.
And that's
it sounds like they're given com
deference to her and to that dec
So remember that this
this grand jury
does not have
the power of the power to indict
She has to now present
that to a criminal grand jury
who can basically take
the summary of the report
and consider the witness testimo
the statements that were made.
They're not bound either
by the special grand jury report
But this is basically an affirma
for for the district attorney
that the investigation
should move forward.
Now, again,
she she looks at it
both from the facts and the law.
And she'll have to take
into consideration the court.
She might be in the you know wha
The jury pool is going to look a
these things
that will have to go into her de
that mean
that she doesn't enforce the law
or move forward on
matters brought before.
But she has to think about these
especially in a case
of this magnitude,
because we are in historical wat
And so
I think she should be doing all
It has been doing it, frankly,
over the last couple of years.